Ngày bá mới thống mời tổ thủ mì đô nên trăm và trụ tịch Trung Quốc tập cập bình đã có cuộc hội đam
chức tiếp tại thành phố Bú Sang của Hàn Quốc, Bé Lê hội nghiệp 8,
lành giấu lên gặp đầu tiên dưa hành lệnh đạo kể đến năm 2020,
2 bên bài tổ lạc quan về khả năng hạ như các tháng tháng thương mai và hương tự kế một thỏa
mời pháp biểu chứ bảo chí ý, ông trọng cho biết một thỏa thương mai có thể được kiến
ngày trong ngày đông thơ hợi khảo định muốn rí chỉ 1 quan hệ tự tơi và lâu dài về bắc kinh.
Về phân mình, chủ tịch Trung Quốc tập cập bình nhấn mạnh, việc tôn tại khá biệt dựa hai nên kinh tế hàng đầu thế giới là có tránh,
sông khẳng định Trung Quốc và Mỹ có thể cùng nhau đã thích vợ nếu hợp tác trên cơ sở tôn trọng lệ nhau.
Ông cuộc kêu gọi giữ vướng đại cuộc để con thuên quan hệ sông phương tiếp tục tiền lên ở đình.
Cô gặp kéo dài gần hai giờ diễn ra trong bối cảnh hai bên đã đạt được đồng thận cơ bản,
tại các phòng gần phản cấp thấp tại của la lắm per trước đó,
liên quan đến việc giảm phê và kìm phát xuất khẩu đất hiểm.
Giờ quan sát nhận định của hội đà mang lại tin hiệu tích cơ sông bận con nhiều bất đồng về đại loan,
công nghệ và phê tán nhiên.
Đây là những vấn đề được xem là phép thử cho khả năng cải thịn quan hệ giữa hai nên kịch tế lớn nhất thế giới.